gunfire
and fear
on the streets of stefanakad the main
city in nagorno-karabakh panic took over
as mortars pounded its surroundings
[Music]
dominated
Breakaway territory is internationally
recognized as part of Azerbaijan but it
is controlled by ethnic Armenians and
has close links to The Armenian
government
it is the source of instability and
tension between the two countries and
the threat of out and out conflict is
never far away
both have gone to war over the region in
the early 1990s after the fall of the
Soviets Union
and in 2020 which ended after a
ceasefire agreement
the latest source of tension is the
continuing blockade by azeri forces of
the Latin Corridor an area of land
linking Armenia to nagora karabakh
preventing those living there getting
essential supplies such as food and
Medicine
Russia one of the backers of the
ceasefire has urged the two countries to
stop the fighting
Russia strongly encourages the
conflicting sides to stop the Bloodshed
stop the military actions at once and
return to a political and diplomatic
settlement
Outside The Armenian parliament in
Yerevan crowds gathered to protest
against the renewed military operations
urging the government to do more to
protect the people in Laguna karabakh as
once again the tension between the two
countries spills over into conflict
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera